Yes I told you so you were in part. Right. What do you think you fifty one.
Yeah I think I think we have a very very creative laboratory
and I like pushing the boundaries into Muslims call disruptive or transformative technology and we have.
You know artists in the lab
and you know I think player would would also I think for fun you know you know science writers I mean yeah I mean.
We don't take ourselves too seriously.
We try to do experiments that are both imp important for something societal but they're also very playful and
and illustrate an interesting way of looking at things is that makes people smile and surprised. Oh. Why is it.
Why do we do that. Why do they smile.
Well some of them were funny like making seventy billion copies of my book that more than all the most welts the
purchase books in history and that's kind of a funny idea and the idea that the D.N.A.
Could last for seven hundred thousand years or maybe a million years is is fun and.
Making a woolly mammoth this for you know you can have a serious reason likes the the survival of the Asian elephant
or but it's also very it's just makes you smile through think that the new
and all the animal that sixteenth comes back when the borders. Yes right. Yes. You know parties are right.
Yeah so in a way that's that's very serious in that. When we started the ten years ago.
There were all these really scary and crazy rules.
That didn't didn't really make sense like through that that your D.N.A.
Would your your information medical information would never Xscape from the lab even though there are multiple examples
like Wiki Leaks and so forth
and then once it escaped would never be read in a fight even though it's very rich data set
and we know we can read the fine. That if we learned something about two that could save your life.
We couldn't tell you because we couldn't give data back to you just all all sorts of crazy things like this.
And so we want to begin to take you know be a little more playful
and say well what if we did just the opposite of are all of those things if they sound a little crazy.
Let's do the opposite. Maybe it'll be either playful or or super sane.
So the it's the it's the only project in the world now for ten years where where you can actually have free access to
human biology genomes environments and traits. It's kind of like Wikipedia for human beings.
So it's revolutionary and playful.
It's a collection of big data of each individual person so it's not just it's not big because a lot of people it's big
for each person and it's the way we think that medicine will be practiced in the future
but we collect medical records a whole variety of measurements that we do every year on D.N.A.
Day where the people come back every year and get an update.
Sometimes new all sorts of new tests and then then genomic the genomic sequence
and a number of other all mix micro biome mix
and viral sequences the things that in your environment that can greatly influence your health.
So the so we get this big collection and we make it publicly available so that anybody in the world can help analyze
and and interpret and understand your genome everybody you know everybody's genome is in the project for future.
So it's not intended to be a production project so much as an inspirational one where where we show people people said
oh you can't do this is a you know it's just it's impossible. And we showed Well it's actually not so hard to do it.
And so now it changes the conversation in so many of the things that we thought were crazy.
Now people agree that maybe we should be sharing data back with the individual getting them properly educated up front.
Admitting that we can't keep the data from getting out in any project in anywhere in the world.
In fact even even medical records in a hospital which have nothing to do research are extremely valuable now they're
twenty times the value of your credit card on the black market so.
Many of these things that were told not ten years ago are now accepted.
So I was those that was the main thing we were going for but
but what what will happen is once once is why they accepted.
We may eventually have seven billion people's genomes and medical records available
and then you can find all kinds of correlations and and what causes diseases and cures you can want personalized.
Not now not only personalized based on your D.N.A.
but Personalized based on your environment as well and most importantly I think is prevention.
So an awful lot of medicine is you wait until it's kind of too late. Where you've got D.N.A.
Damage to your body or you've got cancer and. If you try to catch cancer very very early.
It's really already too late because it's already started.
It's got its mechanism rear revved up to to make more mutations and what do you get.
So basically when you would explain what you were doing. Somebody could years.
Sure we are lab develops radical technologies for reading and writing D.N.A. The same way you read and write a book.
We can do that with D.N.A.
and We've brought the price down by about over a million fold in the books for everybody in the last eight years
or you know for the coming years. What do you forsee near future. Ten years.
Right like yeah well we don't know if we can sustain this incredible exponential speed where it gets faster
and faster every year
but if we can in in in ten years it will be unrecognizable in terms of the technologies we can do will be able to
change agriculture medicine.
Forensics you name an even even information handling that you normally think is the realm of electronics will be
molecular you know what sense is that Chris what is Chris first crisper So in a crisper is a buzz word that that really
is capturing the imagination
but it represents a much broader set of tools that we we've had for a few years to engineer genomes.
So in addition to the the new ability to read genomes.
Christer represents a way of editing genomes is not the only way
but it's it's something that captures people's imagination and we helped invent that.
About three years ago now and and.
Many people have improved on about seventy people who of the labs have contributed to open research nonprofit resource
called add gene and then redistributed them the thirty thousand laboratories. Sorry. So you know go so.
Crisper is the latest in a series of ways of manipulating the genome where you the computer science
and computer defined twenty base pairs eight C's G.'s and T.'s in a particular order chosen to be specific.
For one place in your genome in your D.N.A. and Not anywhere else in your genome so it's both positive and negative.
Computer selection and then it will cut it will search through the genome randomly and find the right place
and make a cut both strands of the D.N.A. and Then that either.
That eliminates the gene that it just cut in or it helps repair to whatever you want.
So that's precise gene that is what people are so excited about where you can change it into whatever you want
and we were the first lab to do that in human stem cells but and those can be turned into almost any cell
and it can be done in a whole variety of different organisms and almost every organism that's been tried it works
and because it's like like you use marketing word. X. Ray. Right right right.
So some people call editing just making a mass breaking making a break.
I think that's that's like that's like saying that.
Ripping a page out of your journal is editing and it's it's not really that. But this allows a very precise editing.
If you read. OK revise.
All right so you can now engineer agricultural species wild species and you can do preventative medicine.
It's not just it's not read these three groups. Is there any writing ours. Right.
So you know it's it's a three year old technique
but it's been growing exponentially in the number of people adopting it is huge and.
And every new person adopts it helps also make it work better. You know. Start to create so for people with very self.
Help those people are right. So it's particularly valuable for.
So-called rare diseases that are individually rare but collectively there's a large number of them.
And so you might have maybe three to five percent of the population is affected by these even though each one only
affects one in one hundred thousand.
Together there and and so if you have two parents that are carriers and they have no.
They will have twenty five percent of their children will be severely affected very deterministic is you know it's not
really probabilistic it's almost guaranteed and that means that.
The only real way that that protects the family including you know the church so the children in the family
or are healthy is abortion which is not acceptable to many people in the world
and so Gene editing go see opportunity of changing the sperm so that you don't have to affect the embryos you can do it
without hurting. Or putting him at any risk. So that's a new possibility that has has has yet to be demonstrated.
Credible future review for developing right.
Which right now you can reduce disease without eliminating the gene variants. Of me viruses or bacteria or. Even that.
Right right.
So we've made by zero containment versions of bacteria that are where are stuck in the lab they can't they have very
low a scape rates
and this particular important if you put things in the bacteria that would give them an advantage in the wild life for
example virus resistant that could be very productive in an industrial setting.
But you don't want that to get out into the wild.
So you have to have both a viral viral anti-viral strategy and the bio containment thought together.
That was actually done without crisper quite a bit of the genome editing in genome engineering we do in our lab does
not evolve crisper and that's a perfect example of one which where we've done probably the most radical
and extensive engineering of four million base pairs. Without the risk for.
Where these these genes as you have your work source. Well I think this.
Those are the source of our industry and enthusiasm is.
Just knowing that you can answer very basic scientific questions at the same time you push you drive down the price of
technology make democratizing it making available to many people
and then the product of the applications of the technology can be even more societal impactful than the technology
itself.
Such as you know transplant patient solving the transplantation crisis the malaria crisis
and aging crisis these these are all things are highly motivational for millions of people are dying every year.
Your purse is my personal energy comes from.
The threat that all these people are going to die every year and the curiosity if playfulness of the science that.
So you could simultaneously play and do something very serious which is saving millions of people when you start.
Yeah I remember when I was a boy in Florida living. On the water on them in the mud.
I would play in the mud and I would pull the creatures out of the mud. And wonder how they worked.
And I would look at my father's medical bag. It was full of drugs and instruments and I said that since so.
So one was very natural and one was very artificial and I was in awe of both of them and then
and then I went to a World's Fair in New York City from always from Florida New York City when I was ten years old
and I and they had created a simulated future.
They had did gone really really far out on making a pretend world where everything you know they had robots that looked
just like a human being and I said. And then I From that day at I could not I could never go back to the past.
You know even though they didn't have a real future it was a fake future.
I could not just anymore once I had seen the future.
That was I had to work on it to make it happen because it seemed very attractive to us.
It's dangerous
and very hopeful to create a fictitious future in such graphic terms where you can walk around it you can taste it.
You can feel it you can see it you know it had touch pads in one nine hundred sixty five where you could draw something
and then they would print out the. Whatever you Drew.
Not on paper but in fabric you could actually make a scarf of a butterfly that would draw with with a pen.
That's that took like forty years before there was anything even similar to that that that the average person could use
or you would use a fair where you know surely future US for you know this right. Well I mean.
To some extent it doesn't have to be entirely accurate.
Obviously it can't be she can't see the future but it just needs to be inspiring
and to a ten year old is particularly easy to inspire. So you might see space colonies.
I think with with humans that are adapted to space.
You know right now our biology is particularly I mean it was not designed for space travel
or the radiation resistance and the bone loss it happens of low gravity.
So those might be some of that there might be you know.
Either conquering our micro biome completely eliminating it
or getting the point where where we are resistant to everything else and so we didn't eliminate it.
We just got better at at vaccination
or I mean I think that I mean so that you can you can now go back to doing surgery without hygiene you just don't even
clean your hands. You know and.
I think there are many things like this that would be there would seem like science fiction
but if you created it in a realistic enough fictional universe people people kids especially will will dream about it
and make it happen. From a should expect. Well I expect everything. Not I made it.
You know it's it's it's funny you know and I when says anything gigantically on it.
Well my family was very concerned because my father had died of senile dementia
and they were worried that I would had some risk factors and so far it looks like I have the opposite.
I have no risk factors so maybe that's surprising. Maybe itself is false assurance.
You know that future was just something that feels like a fortress right.
I'd certainly feels that way to me every day I get somebody walks in and gives me something that shocks me
and it's not easy to shock me
but it's very common that they'll come up with something that really changes the way we approach biological research.
When Well well for example getting nana for sequencing that was some.
It's a way of you have a handheld device that is capable of sequencing D.N.A.
Engineering mosquitoes so that they can spread really good genes through the environment that would make them resistant
to. Malaria parasite. Every little breakthrough in each of those two projects. This is remarkable.
What you think of the creatures. I'm one of the biggest critics of it.
I try to raise consciousness and make people concerned because if you are not concerned.
Things can be unintended consequences if you are concerned. At lower it helps you plan for alternatives and. But.
In particular I suggested over the last eleven years that twelve years that we should have a surveillance mechanism in
place where anybody that participates in these powerful technologies
and all the ordering that they do of supplies should be monitored by the companies
and ideally by the governments as well that I mean that's so you wouldn't want surveillance on your everyday activities
but if you're if you're dealing with synthetic D.N.A.
That's not everyday activity and nobody forcing you to work on synthetic D.N.A.
But if you choose to work on some that if you know than Then you need to be under surveillance. Because.
We're in a time where we don't know what you what how powerful is and so it's better to just have a writhing.
Under surveillance
and in particular why propose was looking for people synthesizing things that are extremely hazardous things like
smallpox and polio and anthrax toxin
and things like that because there's no reason that the only way they should only be ordering that if they have
permission from the government to order it and that very good reason. It's very easy.
And so you know we have to monitor how they order it as D.N.A.
but You need to monitor the machines in the chemicals that they can use to do it themselves.
But if you monitor everything that really reduces the probability they could do it themselves.
It's also yes receivers were able to get. Yeah crisper has a lot of power but it's probably not the most dangerous.
I mean I I'm not trying to reassure people I'm just saying if you're going to worry worry about the right they which is
worry about ordinary pathogens that you can find.
You know in every you know all over the world because those are much more powerful than anything you can do a crisper
today. Crisper is crisper and all of our amazing technology for reading and writing D.N.A.
Is now you can use it for better surveillance.
I mean if it's a million times cheaper you can have it distributed network of surveillance.
You can make faster and better vaccines that are very responsive to emerging threats where the natural or unnatural
and so forth. I think that that that the revolution in reading or writing D.N.A.
Is much more easily used for protection and prevention and it is for misuse misuse you just go out
and get somebody who's got some serious disease
and weaponize them with with ordinary methods not modern molecular biology. And so I mean if you like the way. Like.
This. Well a slight difference between this and the Internet.
I think as we have the opportunity of having a higher security
and safety mean I think in the Internet early days that it wasn't a top priority.
But I think and you ended up with kind of a culture that includes hackers and computer viruses and credit card
or just identity theft and stalking and and so forth and.
I think if you had that the equivalent thing in biology would be much more serious.
So if you have a computer virus some might cause billions of dollars of damage
but a real virus could cause billions of dollars damage
and millions of lives so I think we need to create a culture of surveillance and in good deeds and. You know. Yes.
Yes it is but we need to keep.
Keep raising consciousness and keep that motivation going you know it's good to stay critical.
So this right and where your future or what I please. Once you are getting confused by myself you know self.
Boss and future Fiat humans what do you think that here. But it was definitely the case that that.
One of the distinguishing features of human beings is our ability to think very deeply about the past
and predict the future and thereby avoid future existential risk to ourselves our family
and to in fact the entire planet. So in particular asteroids and super volcanoes could could.
Destroy all of civilization or at least throw it back into the dark ages.
By eliminating the social fabric and cooperation. That and that is that's that's even if we do nothing wrong at all.
That's if we just a you know we we don't create some killer virus we don't pollute our atmosphere would we do if we
don't create global warming.
If we do everything right because we can still buy as a species and so I think the the end of go to.
That is to get us off the planet as a sort of the space genetics planetary species
and we have to start spreading outside of the planet. Also one of your goals.
Yeah I think we have a consortium for space without a center here Harvard but international and
and one of the is to raise consciousness about the needs the special needs that you have.
That have to do with genetics in getting off the planet. You. The beauty of the human genome.
It's beautiful on spiraling because it is in a certain sense very simple and very complicated. There's parts of it.
We don't understand their parts of it that are amazingly predictive and we understand well enough.
It's beautiful and the. It's a simple set of four letters G. A T.N.-C. And so in a way you can you can.
Once you get a little education.
You can read you can read it just by looking at it which it couldn't didn't have to be that simple.
Everybody talks about how complicated it is but really once you have a little bit of training.
It's amazing how much you can get out of human and other genomes. It's a beautiful. Structure.
You know has a very elegant in the two strands in the way it replicates by separating the many things about the end it
is beautiful. You knew can make build machines out of it you can. And you can print books. But you're you.
You're just because you see very soon you are working. You are you are you know everything that comes with the right.
Astronaut driving through writing more and more and more. And that's what we are. I always did that far right.
Yes So when I say is simple. I'm doing it from an unusual standpoint.
It would be like an astronaut saying Oh it's simple to walk on the moon. Well maybe for you. It is.
And what happens is once you get a certain number of technologies working that nobody else in the world can use not
because we've kept it a secret. I mean we've we've shared it openly. It's and we're very interested in open access.
It's just that nobody can. Even though it's open.
They can't Nestle practices that easily or they don't trust it or to be as easy as it looks
and so then we have the opportunity of using it for a couple years and
and putting together another layer of of inventions and another on top of that
and recombining them in various ways to get hybrid inventions
and it just keeps in this positive feedback loop keeps going and it's a very funny.
It's a very funny experience is like. You know it's like diving off a cliff.
You get faster faster as you hit the water. You're looking at.
Yeah there may be what may just be free fall and the free fall with a few people. It's. Because if you. You know there.
There's a.
There's a a large research community but within that as a smaller set the due to technology
and there's even smaller set the does radical basic enabling technology so.
So some of the technology developers might develop a particular drug for a particular disease
but then there's a tiny set that develop technology which can be applied to almost anything so reading or writing D.N.A.
Can be applied to any organism and it can be applied even to things that are not biological like.
But and those tools can be applied to themselves which because what creates this exponential the just growing faster
and faster. Is that the tools that you used to engineer D.N.A.
Can be used to engineer the tools that used to engineer D.N.A. It's very cyclic and and so that's.
That's playful exponentially growing. Means that. Well it goes very possible. What. If you.
Will hopefully what will bring us is is.
Higher safety rather than less safety and that requires that we talk about a lot and to be very thoughtful about it.
Encourage the new generation to be focused on safety security and modeling and. Extensive testing.
But it but other than that. The minute it will bring us whatever we want. It's unlimited that it.
The question is not so much what it will do it's what are the few things that it won't do.
You know for example even computers which currently now are not biological those could easily be biologically the
future the most amazing computer in the world.
Old is is the human mind and
and if that if the human mind starts modifying itself then it becomes even more amazing than than a human trying to
make a computer that fit the can't yet think the way human can. And. Can be there. Will you vs.
Be made as if it could be it yet.
Could it could be revolutionary in terms of how unrecognizable it is a few years from now so fair were you organize
your life. Right. If you were sure what way is right.
I mean it's much easier to illustrate the revolutions in the can I call in electrical engineering.
You know you can build a you know like in days of Edison you can build a crude prototype for a motion picture camera
and projector and that's fairy you can touch it you can feel it you can understand how it works.
If you were to create a futuristic vision today. Most of the mechanisms would be invisible they'd be so small that you.
There's no real way of observing them directly.
And even if you could observe them me it's hard to understand what they're doing because we don't are not used to
thinking the way the molecule thinks like you know.
A molecule might crisper molecule in order to cut it might jump around to six billion different places randomly keeping
knocking on the same wrong door until it finally finds the right place and then it will act.
I mean that's very different from how you would build a cuckoo clock.
You know where it does exactly what you want to do right. So I think people are not you.
Thinking molecularly but I try to encourage my lab to think like a molecule. You know. Just.
Well they don't they're there they're very random they day they and they're fast and so you might try.
You know four hundred times a second to do something and only get it right about once
and twenty like making proteins and rivals some so you know. This is random but yeah.
But also the randomness of the mole at the atomic molecular scale
but then all of the the evolved machinery of life that overcomes that randomness
and makes it very non random survey sample when you're chromosome separate when your daughter's cells replicate.
It's almost perfect. It's not random.
And so that you know what you're doing is using the random noise
and of the energy of the cell to make nearly perfect decisions it should be random
and going back to the idea that you think these we have to create a kind of you can start a sperm and.
There you go wait.
It's changed things for you or you can change idiom before the sperm
and egg get together you can change it in the sperm itself. You know like a human built two point zero.
You can create you. Right. I mean you can you can alter what we were already altering adult humans with gene therapy.
It's not just in ways that that correct something that's wrong with that that correct. An inborn in hair.
To mutation there are even some where we augment them as adults. For example making them resistant to HIV.
I mean it still is medicine because they are they might be at risk or already have AIDS.
But the way you do it is is not by the chemical that kills the AIDS virus.
It's making it's like changing the human body so that no longer has the receptor for the HIV the virus particles.
Now it's like. It's like being not worth it if you are able to.
We're not only facing as you would if you were if you were you were in the middle of this scientific revolution.
That's credible.
You know it's like right now it's not hard to stay motivated
when you have a lot of people in the lab that are enjoying themselves
and making revolutionary breakthroughs on a regular basis very easy to get everybody motivated because I also work for
a literary right at the bleeding cutting edge of science and technology.
So we're going to be working day you're little how do you. If they wasn't that the for radio days.
I usually get up around four o'clock in the morning without an alarm on my own and I work until my wife
and I walk in together or work on the same department same floor. It's just a short walk and so so from.
About four in the morning till about nine I get to do.
Good think and work on it without any interruptions
and then then I then my day is packed with with talking science with my students and post-doctoral fellows
and looking at their experiments and designing and interpret ing and then.
You know I usually don't take a break for lunch or anything
and then at the end of the day I walk back home with my wife and sometimes I get to.
Visit with my daughter and granddaughter who live next door and.
Then that's the sit you know if you meet this you treat your reviewers you know.
Well I'm not a collect Dick I have some kind of genetic problem that makes me fall asleep all the time
and during the day even though I get totally normal night's sleep with you know it's dark it's quiet I'm I fall asleep
quickly at night and I don't wake up in the middle of the night but nevertheless there in the day I fall asleep and
and what happens is I superimpose the dream state on the reality and I can always tell the difference
and I'll talk in my sleep and and but it's sometimes it's very helpful.
Usually it's a nuisance but sometimes it helps me solve problems and makes me look at things differently.
Well I'm not sure I've seen alternative ways of looking at it. The dream state is very. Unusual and and creative and.
Allows you to get out of a rut thinking about things the same way you thought about them before you almost always look
at them differently in dreams.
You're right no no no it's just that sometimes I'll have a difficult sometimes if I have a really difficult problem it
will.
Mice all the shut down and then when I wake up I have the answer is I don't have to write it down
and I now know the answer in other cases it'll just something strange will happen in my right.
A few notes but I'll just forget about it and then.
A month later I'll realize oh yeah that was actually something that was useful. You know. Where you gave expect.
Your work. Yeah.
Our scientific world I mean doesn't really develop itself it needs funding it needs an educated population to support
it and to and to join as is the next generation. So it's very far from self. Renewing.
But there is a component of it where we
and where we might inspire some of the other things that we need we might inspire people to fund as he might inspire.
Youth to join. But a lot of it is it was a very unusual set of motivations and skills.
Not everybody has not everybody reacts to a statement as oh I'm going to look that up you know most people they they
say oh it's I don't believe it or I do believe it.
I don't care but they don't say all look it up on research and I'm going to prove. Disprove it.
But that's almost the that's the natural response of the half and and.
And even if you look at up in use and you see evidence for it in the online
or in the literature you say now I still need to check it.
I need to do a controlled double blind study and make sure that it's really there wasn't any researcher bias.
That's for things. So the scientists are very unusual breed in that sense it's really.
Some of them don't even you know they don't need reminders that this is this is how they is really it's deep in their
body in their soul as to how they. How they think about the world. With deep curiosity playfulness.
But this rigor of inquiry. Were you surprised that there's no way. Yes you're right.
And brought me up that everybody was using because you know it was because for every side as well. Right.
Well most of the technologies are not usable until a technologist makes them usable.
I mean that they may be derived from nature.
I mean in fact they may be very sophisticated machines you know so for example D.N.A.
Plumber race robbers soem crisper these are all very very very complicated machines would be very hard to make from
scratch. You know from first principles on drawing board in.
Any factoring that you can make once you see them you can make variations on them
but making the first one without a hint would be very hard.
But then but then the technologists is needed to change that from a natural form into something that's useful
and then to improve it improve until finally it's usable by non technologists.
And the usual reason they don't pick it up is because the technologist. Either hasn't really made it work.
I mean it sort of kind of works works well enough to publish but not well enough for you to for someone else to use
or it works but it's not very well documented not very user friendly.
So you can like he can have a computer that works but doesn't have any graphics doesn't have any.
And he were real way of. WERNER a person could interface with.
So I thought totally surprising that when people don't pick up a technology what's more surprising is when it takes
when you don't even have to give it a nudge.
It's like crisper you just basically publish a paper in and put some plasmids in and Gene
and suddenly everybody gets the work. That's the more that's the more unusual situation.
You know out of maybe a couple of dozen of technologies I've developed may be five of them are that easy for people to
adopt like crazy. Well you know some things are require a new instrument.
And the new and new instruments require software and Sue got all the engineering conventional mechanical electrical
and software engineering that you need to get them so that takes about five years from the concept to something that
people can use. When you're to have something that's basically what you found in the wild.
Then things that you find in nature tend to be highly evolved this is if an engineer made them
but whether they were involved or however they got that way they're there.
They've got a good user interface sometimes they they they do what you expect those to do. So why is it so general.
You know the general public.
I mean we know scientists pick that up because it's easy to program the G.'s a Stephen C's.
I think it's just John probably they're a little strange.
You know it's like probably the name is a very cute name which was nobody really intensely made a cute name recently
anyway.
Part of it is because you know there was some odd patent issues having to do with the got some people's attention.
I think part of it is just there were like it's like it's like there was a.
Pent up kind like an overdue slot machine or a. It's a tsunami that's coming in off the shore and just before it.
It was a whole bunch of technologies that just before they hit shore.
You know you blame it on one of them what but it's really the whole collection.
So I think it's a combination of those things that the name the patterns and and
and the a lot of the things that came up that have been building up for decades. We were right.
Well I think you know I think it's ability to read and write D.N.A.
and It's some of it's editing and some of it's rewriting D.N.A. From scratch.
There's a whole collection of technologies that is suddenly many factors of ten maybe a million times easier to use
more accurate and less expensive and crisper gets most of the credit
but it's there's this whole other thing sometimes called next generation sequence saying there are ways of synthesizing
D.N.A. On chips these things if you didn't have all these things crisper would be much less interesting. You know.
You know it's so much right for me and my family. Well nobody really knows what it means in the same sense that people.
If you ask even the greatest visionary in computer science in the one nine hundred fifty S.
What the computer revolution meant he or she would. You know probably not guess right.
They probably would not guess Facebook or you know it. Maybe even not even Google search engines or Google Maps.
You know they might as said oh it will be used for calculating logarithms for. Rockets.
So you can do warfare better or we can do accounting better.
So we can so that people don't have to have human calculators. So you know I think the same thing is well for.
What society will do with this enhanced ability to read and write D.N.A.
Is we will modify or selves in our environment and the way we obtain food and.
All the materials that we use including very smart materials like computers all these things will be altered beyond
recognition. In a fairly short period of time. That what we did well I was alive a nine hundred fifty.
Yeah we might be the equivalent time but everything's moving faster now
and one of the things this will be faster is are billeted to reverse aging.
So if we can reverse aging then yes you will definitely be around to see all sorts of things because.
There's no there's no particular there's a lot physics that we know of that requires aging.
We know that there are there's a continuity of law. I think that goes back three billion years.
So there's no particular reason why.
That humans or animals in general have to have to senescent get old and
and break because there's cotton some of the cells in the body keep on living in the in the next generation.
That's where you are. Yes right.
You have a very act we have a very active projects plural on the on Aging reversal not so much on one seventy where you
don't want to prolong the end of life which is unpleasant and expensive
and it where you become you know less productive member of society less engaged you want it what you want to do is
reverse it back to a time where you were at your optimal performance.
You know a young person like sixty five years old. Well it's been it's not only possible it's been done in animals.
And now those animals may or may not be good models for human
but it's certainly is the time is ripe for testing things that either cause longevity in animals
or as universal animals and then test to see if thing cause aging Resulin in larger animals and humans.
Well there are many there are many things that have been shown to increase the animal lifespan by a factor of two to a
factor of ten. There are things that involved. I mean not to get too technical.
But the mitochondria the the tips of chromosomes the teal mirrors the the.
Growth factors and muscle related proteins like myostatin pathway.
So all these pathways are pretty well understood and if you harness a little beach for gene therapy.
Then you can try them separately in combination seen their views particularly easy to go from an idea to a test of it
you don't have to take a side route where you randomly screen through millions of pharmaceutical compounds that reverse
aging right because you're able to offer far that your genes are already.
Well we have lots of demonstrations in animals both of longevity extreme extension of longevity
and reversal in some cases many different ways of doing that
and so we're collecting all of those that are known for small animals and we're applying them to large animals
and humans the gene.
You know coming of the gene therapy trials is much easier but we're still just beginning
and that it's looking very promising but it's too early to say
and something that might even work for large animals may still not work for humans.
What kind of what is a lot of work through no you really think your research for your part where you work you like
these as soon as well I mean top priority. I guess would be transplant patient organs.
Malaria for developing countries and aging reversal for industrialized nations and privet preventative medicine
and general strategy.
And then right behind all of those once those are all working a we you know improve our facing human condition then
space in it's sick. We sure were you. Yeah. So the project the most compelling and exciting.
In terms of applications are transplant patients of organs there's a gigantic need for that gene drives to eliminate
malaria and then for developing nations
and then aging reversal for industrialized nations where most of the morbidity
and mortality is due to disease of aging you know you get the core of that
and then once you have all those things which are drains our economy if you can solve all those and you can reduce
and you have more money available for things like space where we really need to get off the planet old boy super
volcanoes and asteroids. And that has a genetic component as well. While we have.
Radiation sensitivity and our bones rot at low gravity and so even not only in in traveling. Let's say to Mars.
But even once you arrive there it's gravity is thirty eight percent of Earth's And so our body was designed for normal
gravity and as soon as you stop as soon as you don't have normal gravity you have muscle
and bone wasting because the body thinks it's doing a feedback loop a physiological feedback loop to keep everything
right but it's just Eve need to have muscles and bones even and low gravity because you need you know
when you need touch something with weak bones you'll you'll cross your own sound
and you need muscles to move things around. So anyway. Those are some of the things that are.
Problematic in space and also there's questions like What do we bring with us.
Do we bring all the species of the earth or do we leave out the Giant Sequoia and the bowhead whale and smallpox
or do we you know. We could you know but you know it's it is we haven't done that yet. We have not. Really recreated.
And so it's a big decisions whether you take it with you. In fact some of them.
It could be there for their ecosystem is fragile enough that you can't really make it with our current knowledge.
So having the complete D.N.A.
Sequence of everything on the planet may not be enough to recreate some of the more complex ecosystems.
When you say yes that's great. Yeah. Yes We're big on on novel tool sets. You know the story.
So a nine year old girl sent us.
Two copies of that poster and we put it on the wall as but it's based on our she had read about our project.
In the news.
It's a small project
and mainly benefits from the technology we've developed for other projects like human medical research.
But these things we bring the price down a million fold and then you can use it for reading and writing the N.S.A.
From ancient samples
and in the I made it with a mammoth is that the Asian elephant is the closest relative to the mammoth
and it's so close in fact they're both closer to each other than they are to the African elephant
and the Asian elephant can breed
and make offspring children with the African elephant so probably the Asian elephant in the Mammoth are basically very
close to being interfertile And so one way of of focusing on modern day species.
Seas is to extend the range of the Asian elephant it will already play in the snow
but you could extend it all the way out to minus forty degrees in the tundra of Canada Russia Lascaux
and furthermore so you get a benefit to the elephant
but you also get a benefit to the tundra because the tundra is melting and this could
and there's experiments in the field studies that indicate that a mammoth like creature could keep temperature colder
by up to twenty degrees in temperature.
So the experiments were that the idea follow up my experience is that trees Zorba about twice as much light
and so that that's a warming effect and. The grasses.
Have roots that protect from erosion
and then punching down the snow the big you have big flea insulating layer of snow in the wintertime if you punch that
down.
Now you can get penetration of the cold winter air
and these three things put the mammoths were the sort of the elephants or maim us will knock down trees
and replace them with grass and a much richer ecosystem full of some small animals.
Anyway they did the experiment replacing mammoths with a combination of caribou which is one of the biggest mammals
and tanks Soviet tanks that would knock down the trees because caribou can't knock down trees elephants in the way it
was about fifteen to twenty degrees. That is the difference between the experimental and the control site. Yes right.
Yes. Yeah well you haven't scratched the surface yet. But you like. I think we covered a goods sampling of it.
Cover the Personal Genome Project. Data incorporation and D.N.A. Future and we covered it.